[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos de los 100 años
de la radio argentina
[Música]
personados helado
la noche del 27 de agosto de 1920 4
porteños se convirtieron en los pioneros
de la radio en su país fueron bautizados
como los locos de la azotea desde buenos
aires nuestro corresponsal natalio coso
y logró una entrevista con carlos
ulanovsky una de las personas que más
sabe de radio en su país a continuación
algunos extractos de esa entrevista
justamente comenzando por esos locos de
la azotea que hace 100 años le
madrugaron al siglo para empezar a hacer
radio desde 1900 desde el principio del
siglo había un montón de gente
preocupada por el tema de la
comunicación a distancia por lograr la
los contactos inalámbricos y estos
chicos los llamados locos de la azotea
que eran unos jóvenes inteligentes y
inquietos y activos eran
radioaficionados eran melómanos no
casualmente
inauguraron la radio con una ópera en la
misma cuadra del teatro coliseo estaba
la casa de remates que ricky williams
desde los techos de derrick williams
tiraron los cables hacia el teatro
coliseo por eso por eso esa tendencia a
andar por los techos los empezaron a
llamar los locos de la azotea le quedó
para siempre ulanovsky también nos contó
sobre esos primeros años de la radio la
década de 1920 en la cual los argentinos
se volcaban a radios a galena para
captar las ondas a m3 mil 920 mil 930
eso fue la escuela de todas las costas
en términos radiales se crearon los
géneros se crearon los géneros de
repente la orquesta de tango se dio
cuenta que que si iba a la radio podía
transmitir un tema musical que a lo
mejor pronto podía grabarlo y eso le
convenía y lo mismo en 1930 curiosamente
un inmigrante español
hace el primer radio teatro exitoso
masivo es una chispa so de tradición
bueno chispas o de tradición fue tan tan
exitoso que obligó a las grandes tiendas
que funcionaban en buenos aires a poner
altoparlantes segura de sí misma
empoderada la radio argentina llegó a un
cenit a una época de apogeo a mediados
del siglo 20 de que se trató de esta
gloria respondió la cnop skin pero en
1100 mil 935
con la creación de radio el mundo que
crearon a la imagen a imagen y semejanza
de la bbc de londres y también de la rca
víctor de eeuu una radio ejemplar
extraordinaria digamos la radio se
convirtió en el centro del
entretenimiento de cada hogar pero no
solamente eso sino que la radio educa va
a la radio nada
nociones de la vida moderna podrían
recibir una pelea de box en directo o un
partido de fútbol en directo un radio
teatro la orquesta de tango la orquesta
de jazz
el cantante de folklore el cómico bueno
todo pero a la radio le llegaría la mala
hora un declive precipitado por una
apabullante intromisión de la televisión
privada en los hogares de los argentinos
bueno llega la televisión en principio
desde una manera insolente impertinente
le vampiriza todos los géneros a la
radio pero lo que pasa en 1960 y 61 y 62
hasta el 66 cuando se instalan los los
canales privados es mucho más grave para
la radio no porque básicamente lo que
pierde además de géneros de contenidos
pierde publicidad a partir de ese
momento y hasta hoy
hay muchísima gente que dice ah y adoro
a la radio la radio su única no hay nada
como la radio pero primero que nada está
la televisión para ellos ahora en el
siglo 21 con los avances tecnológicos
que han transformado nuestra forma de
informarnos y de entretenernos cómo le
va a la vieja de la radio la verdad con
muchos cambios tecnológicos pero con
pocos cambios de contenido llegamos a la
radio de hoy y la radio de hoy es una
radio completamente rendida la
información a la actualidad porque todo
lo que pasa en el mundo llega a los 10
minutos no menos a los 5 minutos ahora
digo el internet ha vuelto planetaria a
la radio entonces
digo eso es extraordinario dios eso es
una cosa maravillosa yo sigo pensando
que
la radio seguirá siendo fuerte cuando el
frente de un micrófono haya un tipo
inteligente con algo para decir
carlos ulanovsky recientemente terminó
su último libro 36 mil 500 días de radio
100 años 100 voces a él muchas gracias
al igual que a natalio coso hoy quien
logró esta entrevista llegamos al final
soy andrés suárez jaramillo encantado de
que puedan compartir estas historias que
las encuentran en france 24 punto com
[Música]